نحن في معهد البحوث العلميه في كاليننسكي
في مدينه دنيتك هذا المعهد تعرض لقصف
اوكراني مرتين اليوم المره الاولى بسته
صواريخ اوكرانيه والمره الثانيه بخمسه
صواريخ يمكن ان نشاهد الضرر الكبير الذي
لحق بهذا المكان هذا المعهد كان مخصصا
للبحوث العلميه ويجري اليوم
التثبت من الاضرار ومراجعه الاضرار التي
لحقت بهذا المكان يمكن ان نلاحظ الخبراء
العسكريين الذين يزورون تقييما ليس فقط
للاوضاع ولكن ايضا للصواريخ التي استخدمت
في هذا الاستهداف يمكن ان نرى ايضا
النيران التي
المشتعله جراء القاء القذائف على هذا
المركز
العلماء ايضا يقومون بتقييم الخسائر في
هذا المركز العلمي الذي كان عاملا حتى
صبيحه هذا اليوم الحديث عن مقتل شخص جراء
هذا القصف
وجرح اخرين
واليوم هناك مخاوف من قبل السكان في هذه
المنطقه في دنيا انها كانت تعتبر من اكثر
المناطق امنا ولكن بعد هذا الاستهداف لا
مدينه ولا منطقه امنه في دنيا كارمنج خضار
الجزيره